sous une robe sûr sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue dans un europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 60,18
voici le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé marie-pierre vedrenne sera
notre invité l'occasion d'évoquer avec
elle les relations commerciales avec
l'union européenne
stabilité politique une économie
attractive et un niveau de vie attrayant
l'accueil des réfugiés en europe nous
verrons comment ça se passe chez nos
voisins voyager dans l'assiette le chef
du restaurant parisien le sormany nous
dévoilera sa recette de raviolis de veau
aux truffes une recette inspirée par ses
racines italiennes mais tout de suite
que fait l'europe dans notre quotidien
alberto believe aka chargé de mission
europe direct en seine et marne vous
parle des droits des passagers aériens
sous drop
michel delpech dans son morceau chute
d'un avion un soir il chantait ainsi
d'ici le sable est blond dit si la mer
est bleue d'ici on pourrait croire que
les gens sont heureux la terre est un
paradis vue d'avion cette invitation au
voyage est formidable mais il faut bien
monter dans l'avion pour pouvoir prendre
le plaisir de flâner sur les nuages en
effet même si prend l'avion peut être
lié à un moment joyeux comme un voyage
quelques jours de vacances ou un départ
en mobilité il peut arriver que
l'expérience ne soit pas à la hauteur
des attentes
vous en avez peut-être déjà fait
l'expérience vous partez en mobilité
étudiante pour prendre enfin le vol et
votre compagnie vous met du plomb dans
les ailes vols annulés ou retardés refus
d'embarquement
même une petite période de détente peut
vite virer au cauchemar
toutefois même si vous êtes à l'aéroport
désespérez pas de crainte l'union
européenne prévoit un cadre pour que
vous puissiez faire valoir vos droits en
cas d'ennuis lors de votre périple
européen depuis 2004 les passagers des
compagnies aériennes européennes et ce
au départ du territoire d'un état membre
possède des droits en cas d'annulation
de leur vol et de refus d'embarquement
un règlement européen leur garantit en
effet une compensation financière
un réacheminement sur un autre vol ou un
remboursement du billet ainsi qu'une
assistance à l'aéroport en règle
générale la compensation est
actuellement comprise entre 200 et 600
euros en plus si vous redoutez les
démarches administratives que la
réclamation pourrait impliquer vous
pouvez être accompagné en prenant
contact avec les organismes nationaux
prévus à cet effet grâce à ces mesures
vous n'avez qu'à plier bagage et faire
le saut dans l'inconnu pour explorer
tous les recoins du lieu les amis
européens n'oubliez pas votre carte
d'identité nationale munissez vous de
votre carte européenne d'assurance
maladie et ben van
saun robe l'invité politique
je reçois marie-pierre vedrenne bonjour
bonjour à vous êtes membre du groupe
renault europe vice présidente de la
commission du commerce international
ensemble on va évoquer les relations
commerciales de l'union européenne il
existe différents accords commerciaux de
libre échange entre l'union européenne
et plusieurs pays certains sont en
négociation actuellement sur quoi
portent les tractations justement de
manière globale en ce moment en fait il
faut partir déjà du principe qu'un
accord de commerce ça pour ambition de
libéraliser les échanges c'est un mot
parfois sensibles et notamment en france
mais c'est l'objectif faire en sorte au
final de nous rapprocher quand nous
concluons un accord de commerce à la
fois en termes de flux des changes est à
la fois en termes de normes de
réglementation
contrairement d'ailleurs au brésil où ça
a été la négociation d'un accord de
commerce un peu particulier cette fois
avec un état qui quitté l'union
européenne mais c'est vrai que il ya
plusieurs types d'accords il ya les
accords générique de commerce qu'on
appelle les accords de libre échange il
ya aussi des accords sur les
investissements parfois des accords sur
des sujets particuliers nos par exemple
entre la chine et l'union européenne ya
eu un accord sur les indications
géographiques
et puis il faut avoir en tête avec
certaines parties du monde notamment nos
partenaires africains nous conclusion ce
qu'on appelle des accords de partenariat
économique qui sont en fait conclut dans
un objectif d'être à plus favorable sur
l'entrée sont notre marché aux pays
africains alors vous parliez les
négociations avec la chine il ya aussi
le japon les états unis en ce moment sa
porte sur quoi les négociations
est-ce qu'on baisse les taxes justement
de certains de certains produits en
échange de réciprocité sur source là on
avait vu que les états unis avaient
accès des produits européens on avait
répondu en taxant des produits
américains où on sort n'est aujourd'hui
en fait à peut-être avant d'avoir un
focus spécifique sur ces pays d'hier qui
a effectivement il ya des accords qui
sont déjà conclus et donc ils sont mises
en oeuvre et l'enjeu de la mise en
oeuvre est un élément fondamental faut
toujours partir de l'état d'esprit que
on ne conclut pas un accord commercial
juste pour conclure un accord de
commerce n'est pas une fin en soi c'est
effectivement de favoriser les chances
de travailler sur la réciprocité de
gagner des choses dans chaque accord
mais
le sujet de la mise en oeuvre est
vraiment essentielle et c'est là où je
dirais aussi que le bât blesse au sein
de l'union européenne donc il ya des
accords conclus il ya désaccord
effectivement en négociation par exemple
à l'heure actuelle avec l'australie avec
la nouvelle zélande nous échangeons avec
avec ces pays dans l'objectif de
conclure un accord de commerce il ya des
accords qui sont déjà conclus et qui
pose problème l'exemple type le mercosur
a d'autant plus que le débat au sein de
l'union ça fait débat au sein de l'union
dans les états membres et puis il faut
dire que les choses sont un peu gelé a
vis-à-vis de cet accord parce que le
parlement européen a adopté il ya
maintenant un peu plus d'un an et demi
un amendement dont j'avais la charge
pour dire pas de mercosur en l'état
parce qu'on voit aussi que des périodes
de négociations sont parfois très
longues comme celle du mercosur 20 ans
de négociations et en vingt ans le monde
a changé notamment avec la place de la
chine et puis les des nouveaux enjeux
qui émergent en matière commerciale on
veut qu'ils aient plus de cohérence de
notre politique commerciale avec les
autres politiques dont nos gros sujets
fondamentaux à la fois la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique et à la fois
la numérisation de nos sociétés donc il
faut que tous ces accords tiennent
compte de ces enjeux là après pour
répondre à votre question plus
spécifiquement vis-à-vis des etats-unis
c'est un petit peu particulier parce que
rappelez vous il ya eu une négociation
d'un accord commercial qu'on appelait le
type ou le taffetas qui a échoué des
deux côtés de l'atlantique
donald trump quand il est arrivé à la
maison blanche avait dit qu'on arrêtait
et puis côté européen il y avait aussi
énormément de questions parce que
c'était un accord très large et on
n'était pas convaincu qu'il allait
défendre réellement aussi les intérêts
européens donc il faut prendre la mesure
de tout ça et puis je pense que ce qu'il
faut dire aussi c'est que en début
d'année 2021 la politique commerciale a
revu un peu sa stratégie la commission à
proposer de nouvelles orientations
basé sur trois piliers une politique
commerciale ouverte une politique
commerciale durable tenant compte des
enjeux changements climatiques et une
politique commerciale plus ferme et
c'est ce sujet aussi qui nous occupe là
en ce moment spécifiquement avec la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne dont on est qu avec
ce que je vous disais un accord de
commerce n'est pas une fin en soi
l'objectif de la politique commerciale
c'est
réellement défendre nos intérêts nos
ambitions nos valeurs ou avancer ce net
je pensais qu'après après ce qui s'est
passé avec la vente des sous-marins de
justement de la france à l'australie la
volonté de la france en tant que
président du conseil de l'union
européenne pendant les six les six
prochains mois c'est justement d'être
plus ferme à cause de ce qui s'est passé
on sait que c'est certain que c'est
c'est pas que liés à cette situation et
à hocus cette vidéo sur ces oubliés
aujourd'hui ça c'est pas nécessairement
oublié parce que on voit bien que entre
alliés c'est pas un comportement qui est
acceptable après c'est pas question
d'oublier ou pas oublier c'est l'enjeu
c'est défendre nos intérêts et défendre
notre vision c'est pour ça que la vision
française d'une politique commerciale
beaucoup plus faire non la porte depuis
des années et on voit des passes
concrétiser chaque jour j'ai évoqué
l'amendement sur le mercosur il ya aussi
la mise en place du procureur commercial
de niro données qui était une volonté
française qui a été mise en place sous
ce moment là donc on voit les
changements donc c'est en fait un cadre
global qui dit qu' on doit passer du
libre échange au juste échange et qu'on
doit passer réellement sur la défense de
l'entièreté des intérêts européens une
unité européenne et non pas que la
défense de l'industrie automobile
allemande par exemple et c'est vrai que
au delà de locus moi je pense que ce qui
nous a aidés dans cette position là
c'est le choc du coc vide parce que le
choc du coville a démontré notre de
notre manque d'indépendance justement
que ce soit sur la production des
médicaments que ce soit sur les masques
beaucoup de sujets et c'est là où on est
dans une réforme globale de la politique
commerciale la politique industrielle et
la politique de concurrence justement à
ce sujet vous vous êtes rendu aux états
unis avec d'autres eurodéputés cette
fois l'objectif de ce déplacement est
est ce que finalement on ne peut pas en
vouloir aux américains parce que c'est
peut-être un allié indispensable face à
l'asie et à la chine justement en fait
l'objectif est effectivement ne pas
tomber dans une appréciation binaire
pour ou avec les américains contre la
chine ou avec la chine contre les
américains et c'est tout ce concept
d'autonomie stratégique et c'est
justement c'était ça l'enjeu du
déplacement aux etats-unis aussi
d'expliquer notre chemin dessiné par
européenne d'expliquer l'autonomie
stratégique il faut rappeler que le
déplacement que j'ai eu le plaisir et
l'honneur de faire c'était aussi juste
avant le sommet sur la démocratie donc
c'était rappeler aux américains que nous
sommes effectivement des alliés que nous
voulons être dans une logique de
coopération et non pas de confrontations
comme nous l'avons été avec la période
donald trump mais c'était leur dire
aussi que de manière assez ferme que
parfois nous avons des sujets de
différends et notamment sur le terrain
commercial la question de
l'extraterritorialité et des sanctions
américaines sont des entreprises
européennes souvent aussi françaises
c'est la question du fait justement de
ne pas se faire enfermer sur leur ligne
vis-à-vis de la chine parce que
l'autonomie stratégique ça veut dire
pour l'union européenne de décider par
elles mêmes avec qui quand et comment
c'est qu'ils nous font payer la taxation
des gaffes a par exemple en fait je
pense je pense que effectivement il ya
plein de facteurs qui démontre que
l'union européenne a envie justement de
reprendre son propre destin en main
c'est pas question je pense de faire
payer et c'est légitime que les états
unis veulent défendre les intérêts des
américains comme nous nous devons
défendre les intérêts dont le nom n'a
pas assez fait on n'a pas été assez
ferme et de ce manque de fermeté aussi
découle un manque de crédibilité et
c'est pour ça que moi tout le monde en
jeu dans la commission commerce
international s'est passé justement dans
une logique d'ouverture qui est
nécessaire et la logique de défendre un
commerce international basé sur des
règles c'est extrêmement nécessaire mais
on voit qu'on n'a pas cette capacité
parce qu'on n'a pas les instruments déjà
juridique les leviers jean n'a pas la
volonté politique derrière d'aller dans
ce sens là pour être crédible il faut
savoir être fermée il faut savoir
défendre ses intérêts c'est tout ce
qu'on essaye de faire avec ces boîtes à
outils qu'on développe alors on parle de
commerce
actuellement le sujet qui est
incontournable c'est l'écologie quelle
est la place aujourd'hui de
l'environnement du développement durable
justement danser dans ces accords de
commerce alors c'est vrai que j'ai pas
précisé au début que les accords de
commerce il ya une partie effectivement
commercial pur avec la question de la
libéralisation les quotas
et c'est tout ça dans un objectif
justement de favoriser les échanges et
puis il ya aussi ce qu'on appelle dans
ces accords de nouvelle génération des
chapitres dit développement durable
développement durable c'est au sens
large qu'il faut l'entendre c'est à la
fois les questions relatives aux
changements climatiques et à notamment
spécifiquement le respect des
engagements signés dans l'accord de
paris et puis la question des droits
humains des droits sociaux dont qu'on
demande c'est vrai beaucoup plus à nos
accords de commerce parce qu'on veut de
la cohérence entre toutes nos politiques
publiques donc il faut c'est vrai verdir
notre politique commerciale ça passe à
la fois par ses chapitres dit
développement durable dans nos accords
de commerce et là on voit qu'il ya des
faiblesses sur la mise en oeuvre comment
contrôler moi je suis par exemple pour
le fait de l'imposer une sorte de
gradation dans les sanctions c'est à
dire que si nos partenaires ne respecte
pas été des sanctions rapides des
sanctions qu'il nous faut il en tout cas
déjà il faut pouvoir les mettre en place
et ce n'est pas le cas à l'heure
actuelle le mot sanction vous savez au
parlement européen et dans les
institutions européennes est un peu un
mot tabou notamment pour des juristes on
a du mal avec ça mais on voit que
justement si on veut être crédible si on
veut être ferme il faut avoir des
leviers qui disent à nos partenaires
vous ne respectez pas les règles donc
vous savez a des conséquences merci
beaucoup marie-pierre vedrenne d'avoir
été avec nous dans une europe je
rappelle que vous êtes membre du groupe
renault europe et vice présidente de la
commission du commerce international
zone europe chez nos voisins
et chez nos voisins ça se passe comment
c'est notre rubrique en partenariat avec
h au gîte institut des hautes études de
journalisme de montpellier cette semaine
l'accueil des réfugiés avec luis da
desgrées du lou une certaine stabilité
politique une économie attractive un
niveau de vie attrayant de nombreux
facteurs font que l'europe est devenue
une véritable terre d'immigration en
2015 le conseil européen a donc instauré
le programme européen de réinstallation
un programme visant à réinstaller plus
de 22000 personnes qui requièrent une
protection internationale depuis des
pays extérieurs à l'union européenne
vers les états membres de l'union
européenne et le programme de
relocalisation qui consiste à rediriger
une personne immigrée d'un première
étape d'accueil à un autre où sa demande
d'asile pourra être étudiée l'europe a
mis en place divers dispositifs mais ils
restent propres à chaque pays membre de
l'union européenne de fixer son flux
migratoires et de mettre en place des
dispositifs d'accueil historiquement
l'immigration a toujours été très
présente en france comme en allemagne la
france est tout de même derrière avec 13
% soit 8 4 millions d'habitants
immigrants contre 18% en allemagne en
quant à l'accueil des personnes issues
de l'immigration en france on retrouve
des structures telles que les cada des
centres d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile
laissé à eau des centres d'accueil et
d'orientation le ch migrants un centre
d'hébergement d'urgence pour les
migrants et le damier un dispositif
d'accueil pour les mineurs isolés
étrangers le système allemand lui est
quelque peu différent certains parlent
même d'un modèle pour la france mais ce
n'est pas dit avec une politique
sélective et répressive il est cependant
critiqué en allemagne elle reste la
première terre d'accueil pour les
migrants en délivrant le plus grand
nombre de droit d'asile l'allemagne est
également en première ligne lorsqu'il
s'agit de l'accueil d'enfant mineur
malade ou non accompagnés
zone europe voyage
on en vient maintenant à notre rubrique
voyager dans l'assiette cette semaine le
terroir italien est à l'honneur franck
potier sudaro et vincent gutierrez du
restaurant sormany à paris nous
dévoilent leurs recettes des raviolis à
la truffe voici dans les coulisses du
char manie avec un objectif vincent
gutierrez et on va vous montrer comment
élaborer n'aura vu les deux vo qu'on
fait nous même bien sûr on va s'en va
vous passez dans le laminoir la pâte ici
présentes
[Musique]
il ya pensé à farine et la pâte pas trop
hein pas trop d'excédent de farine je
sais qu'il faut pour passer avant dans
le laminoir on va bien passer la pâte
dans le laminoir et vouloir payer voilà
bien la passer au fur et à mesure que
vous la passe et on va réduire le
laminoir à chaque fois voilà
voilà donc au fur et à mesure
avec le laminoir la pâte qui va
s'allonger
et qui va devenir de plus en plus fines
c'est comme c'est une pâte fraîche c'est
bien de préparer la préparation la
veille si c'est possible c'est quand
même mieux que la pâte et le temps de
reposer pour pouvoir la réutiliser le
lendemain faire les raviolis alors il
existe plusieurs façons de faire les
raviolis on va vous montrer une des
façons bien sûr pour les faire pour vous
à la maison le plus simple c'est d'avoir
un petit moule arabes unis comme si tout
simplement vous étalez la pâte le long
du moule vous couper la patte de la
longueur du moule comme ceci donc on le
fait cette manipulation deux fois pour
avoir deux plaques quasiment identiques
comme ici et après on va pouvoir
perfectionner nos raviolis donc après
avoir confectionné à la pâte à raviolis
qui vont aller avec les moules on a
confectionné préalablement ici là par
the vault préalablement préparé pour
pouvoir réaliser les raviolis de vaud
avec la pâte convient d'étaler cette
farce ceux de vaud que vous avez ici on
va là rouler comme ici présentés en
petites boules voyez pour la part de vos
on est un petit peu de farce on les
roule
entre les paumes des mains
voilà jusqu'à obtenir ici
une petite boucle pas trop gros pas trop
petit mois la la la la phase est loin
c'est dur et
pour la confection des raviolis dans un
premier temps on va juste farine et le
moule pour éviter que la pâte colle aux
boules composent la première bande de
patte sur le moule déjà farine et
voilà poursuivre nous allons prendre nos
petites boules de farce de vaud
préalablement rouler pour les disposer
dans chaque petit trou donc on dispose
nos petites boules de farce
[Musique]
maintenant avec un pinceau on va juste
déposer le jaune d'oeuf juste bord pour
pouvoir coller après la deuxième plaque
de pâtes
bon
voilà après avoir disposé la pâte les
farces et le jaune d'oeuf
voilà on appuie un tout petit peu au
qu'elle rentre bien dans le moule après
avoir appuyé sur les boules sans appuyer
trop non plus on va re disposer la
deuxième plaque de pâtes
donc maintenant on va chasser l'air des
raviolis en les fermant c'est à dire
qu'on va bien fermer les raviolis sans
avoir de bulles d'air à l'intérieur donc
on appuie très légèrement sur les
extrémités et puis après d'un côté vers
l'autre donc après avoir chef fermer la
pâte à raviole y avoir chassé l'air d'un
côté puis de l'autre on voit déjà ici à
paraître le moule préalablement découpé
qu'on va finir ici vincent va vous
montrer voilà on appuie et le moule qui
est presque préalablement découpé vous
allez à voir apparaître
ici voyez les petits stries du moule en
appuyant bien sûr le rouleau on voit on
va enlever l'excédent de pâte au tour
voilà donc après avoir enlevé en
appuyant avec votre rouleau à pâtisserie
sur le moule avoir enlever l'excédent de
deux pattes autour on va juste un tout
petit peu farine et le plan de travail
retournez la plaque à raviolis
une fois retournés où vous allez voir
ici à paraître
on prédécoupés
juste ici les prêts raviolis qu'on va
terminer de découpés à la main
[Musique]
alors ici on est sur une roulette strié
pour avoir un côté déco mais à la maison
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'avoir la petite
roulade strié vous pouvez faire
également au couteau tout simplement
c'est un marché signé voilà donc là on
va juste enlever la farine l'excédent de
farine bon là légèrement et on a nos
raviolis
[Musique]
voilà après avoir confectionné nos
raviolis on va vous montrer dans notre
cuisine
comment on va cuire nos ravioli avec la
crème de potimarron qu'on aura
préalablement
préparés et on va vous montrer comment
dresser l'assiette des revenus de vos
petits marron et truffe noire pour la
confection de la crème de potimarron il
vous suffit d'avoir un petit marron ici
tout près sinon retour d'halloween si
vos enfants ont fait des petits dessins
dessus ça fonctionne aussi de l'échalote
un petit peu de beurre du lait de la
crème
et de lui donner sormany of course donc
vous faites revenir dans une casserole
les échalotes juste suis au beurre avec
le petit marc ont coupé en dés vous
pouvez garder la peau si vous voulez un
n'est pas obligé de l'éplucher ça donne
un peu plus de goût à la confection de
la recette est un filet d'huile d'olive
le to va cuire pendant une demi heure
avec un peu un peu de lait et de crème
moitié-moitié l'émoi chez crème tout ça
pendant une demi heure une fois que
c'est cuit vous le passez au bain marie
au thermomix et pour avoir un résultat
qui se trouve ici voilà
toi donc vincent et enfants de chauffer
la crème de potimarron qui va nous
servir à faire le fond de notre assiette
avec levi deux petits marron ici pour la
décoration
l'ocab le manchot fait pour cuire nos
raviolis voilà donc le hamas en est en
train de réchauffer la crème de
potimarron pour avoir une belle texture
l'ebit de potimarron pour la décoration
juste ici nous avons une casserole avec
un peu de fond de veau et du beurre
juste consommer de votre activement
vincent on va accueillir ici nos
raviolis de vaud les plonger dans le
consommer de vaud pour leur donner une
belle texture
est juste avant on va apprendre la crème
de potimarron qui sera john progresser
notre assiette donc là qui sont des
raviolis
en plongeon aux raviolis dans l'eau
bouillante salée pour la cuisson
et comme tout pattes il faut bien les
remuer délicatement un mail et remuez
quand même pour ne pas qu'elles collent
entre m voilà pour la cuisson de la pâte
il faut compter pour de la pâte fraîche
comme ici environ deux petites minutes
petite astuce pour voir s'il a pas de
fuite vous voyez à regarder ici elle
commence à gonfler voilà le ravioli
commence à gonfler 3 juste après cuisson
on va les sortir de l'eau
wen
et on les pose
voilà on leur oppose nos raviolis
dans notre consommer
délicatement et on termine par une toute
petite pointe de cerfeuil
c'est ce qui va nous donner la petite
coloration le cerfeuil dans l'assiette
sur les rails au lit et au final un tout
petit peu de parmesan
ce qui va le parmigiano reggiano ce qui
va nous donner un tout petit peu de goût
mais surtout c'est ce qui va nous
permettre de lier un tout petit peu la
sauce et de bien enrobés nos raviolis
alors pour le dressage on prend ici une
assiette plus tôt avec un fond plat
dans laquelle voilà on va juste dans le
fond de dans l'assiette prendre une
assiette à fond plat il y additionner la
crème de potimarron et ensuite voilà
très légèrement
c'est un jeu d'enfant
ça se fait tout seul vous pouvez le
faire avec vos enfants ça marrant
on dispose dans l'assiette les raviolis
de vaud
[Musique]
voilà
pour la décoration de l'assiette les
petites billes de petits marron on les
parcelles dans l'assiette
voilà donc la recette est bientôt
quasiment terminée c'est une recette que
vous pouvez en l'état la faire pour
halloween pas pas obligé d'attendre la
truffe la truffe noire pour faire là la
recette mais là on va améliorer un petit
peu le quotidien avec la truffe noire du
périgord
que vous avez ici
voilà
on va couper quelques lamelles alors
avec votre mandoline vous avez coupé
quelques lamelles de truffe voilà et on
va venir délicatement posée
nous lamelles de truffe noire sur nos
raviolis pour finir
à la fin assaisonner avec un tout petit
peu de fleur de sel
poivre du moulin et un filet d'huile
d'olive voilà pour finir le résultat de
notre set radio lit de vos petits marron
et lamelles de truffe noire du périgord
chef
betty
zone europe s'est terminée merci aux
équipes techniques du parlement européen
de bruxelles vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission en podcast audio et vidéo sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensations et aussi sur tv 78 rendez
vous la semaine prochaine bonne soirée
sonos robe sur sensations
sont europe
[Musique]